neverending story reality edition Google
executives have expressed their desires
to live forever but Ray Kurzweil
Google's director of engineering has
come out with his specific plan to
achieve eternal life a 67 year old
computer scientist swears by his strict
diet regimen of fruits healthy fats dark
chocolate and up to a hundred co-op
every day to promote brain sexual and
overall health Kurzweil explained the
key to longevity is eighty percent genes
twenty percent lifestyle but if you're
diligent it's ninety percent
intervention in ten percent jeans
unfortunately curse miles intervention
isn't for everyone quite yet the hundred
fields add up to about a thousand
dollars a day alright we've done a bunch
of stories on Ray Kurzweil I'm sort of
fascinated by this because we're living
in the time right now where it might be
possible to live forever Ben you laughed
at when a reporter said diligent because
I don't think you're that you're not
diligent enough he's cool in forever
he's crazy we're not living at a time
work baby we can live forever you don't
think so you don't think that this no
100 pillow eating right and good no no
of course not it's not gonna have not
even debatable I mean what about we're
constantly on where's water we're living
in a time where we live longer because
healthcare so good and we know how to
live better but he takes a hundred bill
500 but it's down from he likes Vidya 30
to 50 and like it starts so normal
you're like healthy eating of of fruits
and and dark and something veteran good
vegetables and and dark chocolate you're
like great oh and a hundred pills a day
at a cost of a thousand dollars he
hasn't figured it out you didn't want to
die a hundred pills a day there's 24
hours a day so that's about four pills
basically for pills an hour it seems
like a lot it's a lot of work when you
want to do that much work I'm not in a
financial bracket for my life to be that
important to say only above a certain
thing do you get to go to Elysium in
orbit right and have the bed heal
everything for you i'm one of the work
or class down here there's coughs and
falls over one day ya know i'm actually
i'm trying to live a little better you
know there's another richard overton
there's a hundred and seven years old
I all right yeah we'd look him here you
live detect he's awesome and so there is
a there is going to a hundred now as a
as a goal you know and I am curious to
see how all of this turns out that
what's gonna happen though is you're
gonna have really you know we talked
about the one percent the ninety-nine
percent out but you're gonna have this
rich level of people who will have
better health care better access to food
and water and all of that stuff and at
the end they'll be able to take all
these pills and there were just gonna
create this system where your people
that are living forever living extended
guerrilla and everyone just dying off it
is a lethal dose they're made of us yeah
the soil arnis or twice oh yeah Hawaii
keep reading about people who are under
seven rich is rich Overton you like your
dad or no donate now know is African
American War veteran who lives in Texas
that smokes a cigar every day and he
still drives entirely I wanna shake his
hand yeah right but not to ours yeah
yeah I think you could take on but you
know you read the stories about the you
know some one hundred thirteen hundred
fourteen year old Japanese woman died
you know not rich uh doesn't seem like
some of these doors but like my doctor
just retired at a very young age and he
retired it turned out not to really
retire but to have families Pam I'm
slightly wrong on the number fifty sixty
or seventy thousand dollars a year like
40 families they paying that much money
and then he just he's there dr. any
comes and you don't pay anything else
you sick he comes to your house or you
go to his office and he takes care your
kids and all your blood works free and
like that's the new he realized I can do
this I have enough client I suppose if
you were worth 12 million dollars that
that might be a useful way to get
medical care but obviously that is a
level of care that the overwhelming
majority of people are not gonna say we
already have this little bit yeah yeah
and this guy has how's he getting these
pills you know anyway would you even
want to live forever do we lose
something that's very human if the thing
never makes the full circle let us know
your thoughts in the comments right down
below